nevers qu'on l'a alors on y va les
tombeurs si je résume vous avez chacun
payer 10 euros pour qu'elle vous
enseignent comment on paie somme c'est
ça
vous êtes avec la loi mais j'entends pas
ouais elle arrive d2d des tentes et des
gares aux quais un peu trop des terriens
j'ai cru que tu allais morts l'afrique
doit faire un truc pour google parce que
vous marchez criblé de balles rôle c'est
de la psychologie comportementale
amoureuse
du coup on va voir comment vous vous
démarquez on s'assume ans des lunettes
ça fait pitié
c'est moi papa laquelle on doit gagner
un mec mais fais gaffe à l'aimer tous
surtout pas sourire c'est la meuf qui se
dit vous avez les recours légal comme
soyez et ben vaut mieux entendre ça que
d'être sourd un simple curiosité des
choux gras profond
et à les voir une fille de joie non à
leicester tout par la gueule
[Musique]